on va parler maintenant de la défense du
patrimoine
c'est peut-être grâce à des citoyens qui
ont été vraiment surpris de voir cette
enseigne sur le côté qui était démontée
de l'édifice où se trouve où se
trouvaient les librairies archambault
les exemples récentes démolitions
d'ailleurs c'est la maison boileau à
chambly et les travaux au moulin de
l'île verte et le retrait également donc
de cette de cette enseigne qui soulève
beaucoup de protestations d'une aube à
barroux et directeur des politiques à
héritage montréal est avec nous ce matin
pour nous en parler bonjour bonjour à
entrer tout de suite spécifiquement dans
le détail oui on voit l'ancien garage en
bout de moi m'ont a l'impression que ce
que les citoyens sont pas plus éveillé
plus sensible la protection du
patrimoine
on dirait que nos élus ben écoutez c'est
un bon signe parce que c'est des valeurs
de société le patrimoine c'est pas juste
des piles de papiers à part faire passer
d'un bout à l'autre du bureau lundi par
des procédures bureaucratiques
on voit ces situations depuis au moins
hier on a eu une bonne nouvelle pour le
patrimoine la mairesse landes s'est
impliqué puis en fait sauvé cette
enseigne qui franchement un peu est
invraisemblable qu'on arrive à héritage
montréal à convaincre des compagnies
multinationales américaines de sauver la
part in five roses qui connaît des
grandes compagnies de montréal du québec
qui qui sont aussi indifférente que ça
alors ça c'est assez étonnant
mais l'intérêt des citoyens souvent se
manifeste par des des questions des
protestations mais en quelque part il
faut trouver le moyen de se vendre et en
2018 on n'est pas dans les années
soixante et dix on devrait avoir des
solutions s'il est ce que c'est normal
c'est ce que ça vous surprend à ce que
ces mêmes légal que des compagnies
décrochent des anciens comme cela des
mots liste des maisons
et puis c'est fait avec l'approbation de
la maison à chambly elle appartenait pas
des méchants spectateurs c'était la
ville de chambly et non pas juste des
médias maison ils ont envoyé à pépé pour
excaver pour que plus ils ont
complètement exterminer de ces deux là
alors des fois faut se poser la question
si la l'idéologie la doctrine qui
prévaut depuis une trentaine d'années de
transférer des pouvoirs aux
municipalités en fait c'est pas juste
une question de pouvoir plus personne a
des devoirs en matière de patrimoine
alors ça c'est faudrait peut être
réfléchir là-dessus dont vient de
réformer la loi il ya quelques années
mais on est encore avec une loi qui est
pas prête pour le 21e siècle de la
population s'il faut vraiment
pouvoir de dire oui la pépine roche est
ce que c'est un fonctionnaire anonyme
dans un bureau quelques pas ou si c'est
un conseiller d'arrondissement c'est un
maire normes et ça dépend des villes
depuis 115 autres des sociétés
d'histoire des comités de citoyens ils
ont célébré l'action de les quinze ans
dans le mile end d'action ce patrimoine
donc c'est un peu présents ce qui fait
qu'à montréal il ya d un regard cv que
les médias sont des partenaires de ça
mais dans d'autres municipalités on est
dans des huis clos en sus potro qui
est-ce qui décide mais on connaît le
résultat le pain porte la procédure on a
perdu du patrimoine que la patrimoine
malgré ce qu'en pensent les
administrations chambliss pas parce que
tu détruis après si tu mets plein sud et
reproduit ben c'est ce que veulent
absolument décrocher archambault quelque
part un autre magasin rebâtir une
réplique de ces maisons est ce que est
ce qu'on rend justice à notre patrimoine
est ce qu on le sait reste du patrimoine
mais mettons qu'archambault c'est un peu
différent de la maison placo question
d'authenticité vous savez c'est
l'intégrité la ce policier commissaire
charbonneau qui en occupent les gens
patrimoine s'intéresse à ces mêmes
concepts depuis des générations
puis vous voyez vous mon voile à peine
de l'oeil si on voit qu'il ya des choses
qui peuvent se faire et ce qu'on trouve
un petit peu de valeur c'est que trop
souvent dieu est un geste politique ou
c'est injuste c'est un pur du problème
économique mais on a fait ce qu'on a mis
ensemble la science avec la société
services et des valeurs qui touchent à
la fois la science ce système les
politiciens rentrer là dedans puis il ya
certains politiciens qui pensent qu'ils
ont la science infuse
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas ça
fait beaucoup de dégâts pas juste en et
changement climatique aussi pour le
pétrole parce que c'est beau mais
reprenons l'exemple
boileau oui c'est bon nous a dit écoutez
ça coûte tellement cher la remette à
niveau on pouvoir la visiter
bon il ya cette dépense là est ce que
les gens elle est la voie serait allé la
voir
maintenant on a cet été qui les bloque
bah écoutez il ya un équilibre à prendre
la rationalité derrière ça un petit peu
c'est un processus de valeurs de société
donc ça prend des processus public pour
juste des décisions de sur un coin de
bureau à montréal on a perdu des
dizaines de milliers de maisons sur des
décisions qui se faisait à huis clos à
l'hôtel de ville on a développé des
processus de transparence mais je pense
la société sa fermeture pour faire des
choix des choses des fois si les choix
sont tristes mais les gens peuvent
comprendre ce qui s'est passé à chambly
c'est incompréhensibles et
injustifiables
bon écoute et on verra ce qu'il en
adviendra merci beaucoup avait
clairement ce matin merci aux bonnes
semaines